ça vous regarde présenté par Myriam en
Kawa chaque jour un sujet de l'actualité
parlementaire décrypté faut voir que ces
prestations avaient déjà été
revalorisées au début de l'année une
gravité d'entrée de jeu ça se justifie
on voit que bien sûr les éléments
internationaux impact négativement
l'économie française des débats entre
députés et experts nous sommes élus pour
cela pour agir avec nos différents
programmes de différentes lignes de
différentes nuances l'idée finalement
ces jeunes de banlieue la seule chose
qu'on peut leur proposer c'est des
empereurs low cost sans véritable droit
ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée ça vous
regarde sur LCP et LCP.fr